السؤال الاهم اذا لماذا يشارك الموظفون
مقالات لم يقراوها والاجابه كالتالي في
دراسه بريطانيه اجريت في عام 2022
اكدت ان الناس يربطون المشاركه بالمعرفه
بمعنى انهم يعتقدون ان سلوك المشاركه
الخاص بهم يشكل توقعات الاخرين فيما يتعلق
بما يعرفونه الدراسه تشير الى ان الناس
يعتقدون بفكره الربح بنقره واحده فالفعل
البسيط كمشاركه مشاركه شيء معرفي ما على
صفحاتهم تجعل الاخرين ينظرون اليهم على
انهم اكثر درايه الباحثون اشاروا الى ان
الناس ما زالوا يعتقدون ان الاخرين يعرفون
ما يشاركونه حتى لو لم يقرا هؤلاء شيئا من
مشاركوها عبر صفحاتهم في مواقع التواصل
وينسى الكثيرون ان ما يشاركه الناس في بعض
الاحيان هو مجرد اشاره الى الاهتمام او
حتى مجرد اشاره الى الرغبه في ان يبدو
مهتمين او حتى مهمين
[موسيقى]